spider-man far from home is blowing
people away at the box office
and the latest hit from Marvel Studios
is chock-full of inside references and
easter eggs that even the most hardcore
fan might miss here's a spoiler filled
look at some small details you may have
missed and spider-man far from home
in a cute running subplot throughout far
from home Peters man in the chair and
all-around best buddy Ned Leeds has a
whirlwind relationship with Betty Brant
one of the other students on their
school trip to Europe they fall for each
other on the flight across the Atlantic
become a couple and then break up on the
return trip it's funny and cute I
resumed my first love I had just
finished my own coffee
funny and cute though a to adjectives
fans never would have applied to the
relationship between Ned and Betty in
the comics originally one of Peters love
interests Betty Brant ended up marrying
Ned Leeds who in the comics was an older
reporter at the Daily Bugle were the two
words the marriage was difficult with
multiple separations and Affairs like
their movie counterparts the
relationship ended in Europe but under
very different circumstances sets up as
a scapegoat for the crimes of a super
villain known as a Hobgoblin Ned was
murdered by assassins in Berlin leaving
Betty a widow
yikes one of the main plot lines and far
from home is Peter Parker's crush on
fellow students MJ he has a whole plan
laid out to tell her how he feels only
things keep getting in the way things
like for instance supervillain attacks I
had to plan with this girl that I really
liked him
how it all ruined but there's one other
stumbling block Brad Davis another
schoolmate who also is romantically
interested in MJ and will do anything in
his power to stop his rival so it will
come as no surprise that Brad played by
Remy he is actually straight out of the
comics well one comic anyway amazing
spider-man issue 188 during a period
where Peter and MJ were on a break from
their on-again off-again relationship
MJ brought star college quarterback Brad
as her date to a group outing leading to
a loss of awkwardness it didn't last
though after that one story Brad was
never seen or heard from again until now
spider-man's classic black costume is
famous among comic book fans and
moviegoers alike as the alien symbiote
suit was featured in both Sam Raimi's
2007 film spider-man 3 and the 2018
smash hit venom but the new black suit
spider webs and far from home also has
its own secret past in the comics in the
2004 series secret war Nick Fury recruit
Spidey to help on a secret mission in
Europe and gives him a special black
stealth suit which is exactly what
happens and far from home as well now if
only we can get that eagerly awaited
light Monkey spin-off movie drawing
Peters initial meeting with Jake
Gyllenhaal's Quentin Beck aka Mysterio
the supposed superhero spins a story
claiming to be from an alternate reality
where Earth's heroes failed and the
world was destroyed it was initially
seems like a random word salad Mysterio
says that the MCU version of Earth is
actually designated earth-616 while his
alternate reality has a designation
earth 8:33 fans of DCs our reverse shows
on the CW may recognize this as a joke
about all the various alternate Earth's
and the DC multiverse which are given
designations like earth 1 earth to earth
37 and so forth these must be different
here
my erth erth nine and that's totally
true but this particular joke actually
originated in Marvel's kept in Britain
series from the 1980s the gag was that
the marvel universe was earth-616
because it isn't any more or less
important than any other universe and
the eight three three designation is far
from random either in the comics earth
a33 was indeed destroyed and the only
survivor was an alternate reality
version of spider-man hmm at the very
end of far from home
the final post-credits scene revealed
that Nick Fury was actually Talos the
scroll leader from Captain Marvel
meanwhile the real fury is vacationing
on a beach which turns out to be just a
holographic projection on a spaceship
the real easter egg here though isn't
the scrolls at all it's the fake beach
fans of Marvel's agents of shield may
recognize this sequence as a nod to
project Tahiti
after Agent Coulson died in Avengers he
was brought back using the blood of a
Kree the sworn enemies of the scroll
shield then implanted fake memories in
Coulson so he thought he had been
recuperating on a beach in Tahiti just
like fury well-played marvel at the
beginning of spider-man far from home
Spidey joins are made for a charity
event aimed at helping people who have
been displaced after returning to
existence at throne the events of
Avengers endgame Spidey has an awkward
press conference there's a cute exchange
between Aunt May happy Hogan and a
gigantic novelty check it's fun it's
sort of a big nod to the comics where
aren't may also runs a charity called
feast feast first appeared in the comics
in 2008 amazing spider-man issue 546
before making a prominent appearance in
the 2018 PlayStation game spider-man
cool check out one of our newest videos
right here Plus even more looper videos
about your favorite superheroes are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]